One of the things that I've been
realizing
as a consequence of going through these
stories is that
the degree to which there are about
individuals is quite remarkable and I
think that's really telling,
you know,
one of the reasons I prefer Dostoyevsky
Tolstoy because Tolstoy is more of a
sociologist.
He's more interested in the relationship
between groups of people.
This is an oversimplification because
obviously Tolstoy,
he's a great author,
but yeah,
I like Dostoyevsky better because he
really delves into the souls of
individuals and I think it's remarkable
the degree to which all of the stories
that we've covered so far in genesis are
about individuals and they're quite
realistic,
which is quite remarkable too.
They're not really romanticize to any
great degree because all of the people
that are regardless,
regardless,
let's say as patriarchal or matriarchal
figures in genesis have no shortage of
ethical,
different,
no shortage of ethical flaws and also no
shortage of difficulties in their life
and the difficulties are realistic
there.
They're major league problems,
you know,
like familial catastrophes and famine
and war and revenge and hatred and all
those things.
It's not a,
it's not a pretty,
it's not a pretty book and that's one of
the things that makes it great.
I mean that's one of the things that
characterize this great literature
right,
is that it,
it doesn't present you with a
whitewashed view of,
of,
of humanity or of existence.
And that's really a relief I think,
because as you all know,
because you're alive,
there's no such thing as a whitewash
existence like your to be alive is to be
in trouble ethically and existentially.
I've been reading this book recently,
I'll talk about it a little bit later.
It's called better never to have been.
And it was written by a philosopher in
South Africa in Cape Town named Ben
Atar,
that's his last name.
And he basically argues,
I think it's a specious argument and I
think it's artificially constructed,
but he basically argues that because
life is so full of suffering,
even good lives are very much full of
suffering.
That it's wrong to bring children into
the world because the suffering
outweighs the good even in good lives.
And it's actually wrong.
It would also be better not to exist for
exactly the same reason.
And my sense in reading the book is that
he came to that conclusion and then
wrote the book to justify it,
which is actually the reverse of the way
that you should write a book.
What you should do when you're writing a
book is you should have a question and
you should,
it should be a real question,
right?
It should be one you don't know the
answer to.
And then you should be studying and
writing like mad and reading everything
you can get your hands on to see if you
can actually grapple with the problem
and come to some solution and you should
walk the reader as well through your
process of thinking so that they can
come to the,
well,
not necessary to the same conclusion,
but it at least track what you're doing.
And I don't think that's what he did.
I think he wrote it backwards,
but then an a and so I was thinking
about it a lot because that's actually a
question that I've contended with in my
writing.
There are Memphis to Ophelia and are
satanic figures,
for example,
in girth is Faust and also Ivan in the,
in the,
in the brothers Karamazov who basically
make the same case,
you know,
that existence is so rife with trouble
and suffering that it would be better if
it didn't exist at all.
And the problem I've had with that,
there's a variety of them,
but one of the problems I've had with
that is what happens if you start to
think that way?
Because what I've observed is that
people who begin to think that way,
that isn't where they stop.
Like it,
they get angry at existence,
which is what happened to Cain as we saw
in the Cain and Abel Story.
And then the next step is to start
taking revenge against existence.
And that cascades until it's revenge
against.
While I think the best way of thinking
about it as revenge against God for the
crime of being,
which is I think the deepest sort of
hatred that you can entertain.
And,
and,
and when you're in the grip of a really
deep emotion,
like a really profound emotion,
right at the bottom of emotions,
you're in something that's like a quasi
religious state.
And that's more or less independent of
your belief,
say in a transcendent deity.
I mean,
you can be in a profoundly emotional
state that's as deep as it can be and it
can have religious significance without
that necessarily signifying anything
about a transcendent be it,
you know,
but,
but then I was thinking,
you see,
the problem with that argument is you
can gerrymander it endlessly.
You know,
because first of all,
how do you measure suffering and how do
you measure happiness?
It's like how do you assign weights to
them?
And God,
there's just no way of doing that.
You have to do it arbitrarily.
And so you can make an argument that the
suffering outweighs the happiness.
You just wait the suffering more heavily
than you wait the happiness.
And that's the end of that,
you know?
And so that's,
that's a problem.
But I think there's a deeper problem.